[Music]
a third night of protest
hundreds of people on the streets in
brooklyn center their anger
clear and raw as the clock ticked
towards curfew time
the police declared the gathering an
unlawful assembly and told people to
clear the street
statute
[Music]
they fired tear gas and moved in in
large numbers all
in riot gear they were met with water
bottles
fireworks and contempt
earlier there'd been a peaceful vigil
for dante wright the 20 year old shot
dead on sunday
more than 600 gathered some traveling a
long distance to be there
the hundreds here say this is no longer
just about dante right or other cases
like him
this is about a demand for fundamental
change
to the way the police operate in the
united states
the system it needs to be changed one it
was based on racism
in the first place and so once people
understand that and know that we need a
different form of policing
that is when real change happens a lot
of the things are mental health we need
more mental health workers in our
communities and on our streets
that's what we need here we don't need
more militarization of our police forces
the authorities hope the resignation of
the police chief and the officer who
fired the fatal shot
would lower the emotional temperature on
a freezing night
the departures announced earlier in the
day by the mayor
we have received a resignation a letter
from officer kim porter
and uh in addition to that uh we have
also received
a lot of resignation
uh from the police chief kim potter a 26
year old veteran of the force
was the officer who fired the fatal shot
she now faces possible manslaughter
charges
the family of george floyd took a break
from the derrick chauvin trial in
minneapolis
to offer support to the wright family it
is
just something i could not
fathom that in minneapolis
minnesota a
suburb 10 miles
from where the shelving trial
regarding george floyd was
taking place that a police officer
would shoot and kill another
unarmed black man the police say the
shooting was a tragic mistake
the officer intended to pull a taser but
she drew her gun
instead it's not a story the family is
buying
how many times in training over the
course of 25
years has this officer pulled
aimed and shot her firearm in practice
so don't tell us it's an accident
because it undermines the tragic
lost life that this family has
experienced
the protesters say they'll be back again
on wednesday
and every night it takes until they see
justice
alan fisher al jazeera brooklyn center
minnesota